michael david
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm eating turmeric soup
from the chocolate powder just went down
my throat
i'm stopping now is this why you're
calling me no no no no no no
i'm calling
i'm sorry
okay
craig you you realize that we are trying
to decide whether drastic steps need to
be taken look i'm sorry i didn't know
well the point is that this doesn't
exactly bode well for your branch oh man
you know what michael made that stupid
movie he doesn't get in any trouble
maybe i should have slept with you too
ah what's up
what's with jan and michael
i don't know
where to begin
[Laughter]
my ball
michael
i am calling to see if you would come
down and interview for a job we have
opening up in corporate
really week from today bring your first
quarter stats and your recommendation
for who take over the scranton branch
wow
i wish i had prepared something to say
that's not necessary god
guide you in your quest
yes
david
oh
michael are we all set
isn't
our interview tomorrow
yes
i just happened to be in the
neighborhood thought i'd drop in say
hello just happen to be in midtown
manhattan
i thought i'd catch a show
millionaire workday now
michael david wallace what is this about
dismissing the ad people yeah i'm glad
you called ryan is being a little [ __ ]
again come on michael what's up my
brother
listen
david i would like to do this ad
in-house i want to use only
the creativity that we have right here
in the office
and i will send it to you tomorrow
morning take a look at it if you do not
think that it's ready to air
send the ad agency back down here and
we'll do it on my dime
this is weird michael is everyone okay
oh
well i'm afraid not toby flenderson
of hr has made a sudden reappearance
i don't understand is anyone hurt
not on the surface no but i can tell
people are disturbed david michael
you texted me 9-1-1 call me all in caps
do you know what 9-1-1 means i learned a
while back that if i don't text 9-1-1
people will not return my calls um but
now people always return my calls
because
they think that something horrible has
happened i'll call him i'll call david
no you won't because he's not picking up
his phone yes i will because i always
know how to get through to him
he told me where his kids go to school
i call the school i tell him i'm a
pediatrician they pass me through to his
secretary
i use my little girl voice
but a bing bada boom
hey sweetie what is it it's not sweetie
it's michael scott
what the hell stephanie could you hop
off please michael
i have never david never ever david you
are on speakerphone with the entire
branch and the warehouse hey david hey
i took the liberty of preparing for you
a cheese platter which i will place here
on the eastern wall of the conference
room cheese platter oui mousse from the
wisconsin region a nice firm cheddar
also from the great city of wisconsin an
aged parmesan
here you will find a cheddar style
spread which has reacted nicely with the
air to form a light rind which i think
you'll find both challenging and
delicious at that point i would
recommend you take a quick trip south of
the border to the great state of
illinois where you will find this fine
blue cheese dressing if i may be so bold
it's a lot of fun to let the goldfish
take a little swim in the blue cheese
bon appetit
all right well i should go
thanks for this
you've given me a lot to think about
please promise me you won't do anything
until we speak no no i won't
all right thanks for taking the time
yeah appreciate it thank you
aaron
is michael i think
he's around here
is that
hey hey you must walk right past me how
you doing uh yeah could we talk in your
office yes definitely
okay
yes michael what is so urgent david
guess who i am sitting here dressed as
i'm not going to guess you could tell me
or i will hang up i will give you a hint
his last name is christ
he is the power of flight
sabre is changing everything
sight blockers
they don't let us use cups so i started
thinking who could handle this who would
know what to do david wallace would know
what to do
what should i do david wallace
i don't know what can you do
exactly what are you thinking
it's a tough one it is a tough one i
don't have any ideas for you then yeah
but one would be good
hey oh okay wait okay
i want to tell you about a business idea
i have
okay okay you know how kids leave their
toys everywhere
so this
is a vacuum it's like a shopback type of
thing
teaches kids how to pick up their own
toys
right baseball gloves uh hacky sacks
drumsticks nah
fix it up so the kid's making the noise
pick it up no no no no that's the that's
the vacuum nose okay
you you know
no no no no it's okay another guy from
dunder mifflin arnie from research he's
gonna drop the prototype
and uh
it's like a shop bag
say that yep
hey you know if you want i'm sure i
could get arnie on board you want to
join us for a second
work together again the what
suck it that's what it's called oh okay
huh catchy kids will love it i care
there are very few things that would
make me not want to team up with david
wallace
and suck it is one of them
see you later oh my god i know thank you
for coming thanks for having me
well that's not the david wallace i
remember
that
is some sort of
weird creature
that lives in david wallace's house
no my god
all right let's get me out of here
[Laughter]
what a mess
what you gonna do
you wanna take
[Music]
[Music]
i may have heard from an old client and
i may have immediately started spreading
the news to other clients and potential
clients yeah
but i'm not here to talk about that i am
here to talk about suck it
suck it
you're better than this
yeah i know
everyone's better than this because this
is the worst thing i have ever seen
why they had coconut i miss original
hey
hey guys
a long time
david what are you doing here is it true
you're buying the company
okay hank
i guess the word is out uh please keep
this a secret
but yes i've been talking with andy what
i thought i heard my name what
i'm the new manager
i'll get to it in a second andy but it's
it is it is me right yes that's as we've
discussed what but
it's very oh my god probably
wow from janitor to manager yep
it's quite a cinderella story from m.o.p
to
mvp
there's an official announcement a few
details from the total loss to total
boss
i mean can't we expect any payroll
interruptions now that is a great
question stanley right now i think all
your operations or most of your
operations are pretty much down in
florida so the shift back i was so
looking forward to that and it did not
go as i thought it would
you